hat sie hat auf mich durch den in den
medien in denen in die nähe
jetzt bist du in der mittelalter jetzt
gibst du der mittel com gmbh kids gibt
es dann ernst
es ist sich an social skills und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft wir spielen heute 64 williams
dankeschön ok schwert kompass und ein
rüstungsteile schon eine gute sache zack
zack zack zack kurs durch sortieren so
läuft wir spielen auf von new york das
service kommen hd dürft ihr
wahrscheinlich wissen von new york ist
eine map mit der ich mich wegen nicht
hundertprozentig wohl fühle weil ich die
kaum kenne ich spiele so selten drauf du
kommst mir dann musst du hast du oder
hast du was aber nicht egal aber ich
mache mir den kilian für die sets ganz
wichtig wo doch die hatte was partie
hatte doch am buß- oder mit ihr was ist
los mit leuten irena auf mich zu die
habe keine waffen
finde ich super gau kommt man bei allen
chat werden soll ein bisschen job man
action okay ich hole mir ich wollte max
bild kubisch geliefert
sagt jetzt verstehen sehr schlecht ok am
heuten die bäume ohne es weg nice plate
gleich 300 punkte geholt
erfolg ist wie so eine map wie gesagt
ich spiele vollen york so selten weil
ich mittlerweile einfach immer forster
vorne für das absterben
mit nur bei uns stehen ja ein bisschen
weit weg jetzt wo das noch keiner wagt
etwas erfahrung sprechen mit meego haben
wir mittlerweile keine pfeile
mittlerweile peace & peace versenkte an
alles klar so dass jetzt optik keine
mich der hinterher
wer einer feinen bogen keiner von euch
pfeil und bogen
wir lassen den käse es hat keiner von
euch fall am bogen geben anlegern
zumindest mal so golob zu essen
vielleicht werden ja ich weiß es nicht
könnte man noch so machen egal wie
problems erstmal so also ist auf jeden
fall ihre warmen ihre waren deswegen
setzt sich auch bald entdeckt ob es zum
eigentlich sehr selten aber heute ist
man denkt ob bei mir bis 34 grad bei
euch wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
wärmer
liza wasser im wasser kaffee einer tasse
mit geben vielleicht sogar oder levi
boost einfach nur überhaupt hätten
heiltrank stadt arbeitet entweder die
schlechte waffe und hat seine waffe in
der hand gehabt sehr gut sehr gut
damit reicht es auch für ihn der nächste
so
guck mal die hightech auf die drei den
besseren hellmann und dann geht's ab er
hat auch nicht die beste waffe zu holen
links rechts sagt sack bisschen zickzack
sehr schön kanns nicht getroffen glaube
ich nicht und der hat neiße rüstung und
richtig viele pfeile schön voll zur 84
wie immer in gold erfüllen wir können
nicht mal aussortieren hier kurz
ich brauche nicht brauchen wir nicht
formal nichts sagt nein nein nein es ist
mein haushalt wir machen den so alles
klar gut an so weit passt hier noch was
drin
gut so ab zum nächsten gegner ich hab
mir übrigens oder warum ich das
überhaupt haushalt haushalte ihr diese
diese hitze das liegt daran dass ich mit
ventilator gekauft habe leute gestern
beim baumarkt und es war das kann ich
jetzt schon mal sagen eine der besten
entscheidungen meines lebens weil ohne
ventilator einfach nicht auszuhalten
wäre hier aufzunehmen mehrere aufnahmen
versuche zu haben oder generell auch zu
streamen es geht überhaupt nicht ohne
ventilator richtig froh drüber
ventilator ich mir geholt und mit dem
gitter so dass ich diesen sommer jetzt
auch überstehen kann ohne richtig hart
zu leiden da versuchen wir wissen in die
wand zu boxen jetzt durchziehen
er ist sehr gut nicht zu gegner so da
ist und dem was ich mache wenn ich ein
kind hab immer direkt nach dem nächsten
gegner ausrichten weil die im
zweifelsfall immer schneller kommen als
man denkt
ja kommt sehr schön alles klar nächster
gegner ist wo ein schwert erstmal nehmen
hier nehmen immer neben dem bach
dankeschön okay gut wir können nach
vorne lackner klientel so 7 tnt zwei
diaz wir können uns ein die ihr schwert
machen frage ist wo ist der spot und
hier liegt hat auch mega es keiner
gesehen hat keine gesehen kann der
gesehen leute und ich mache die fünf
liegestütze für den nicht vor allem
einfach am ende am ende der runde
ich muss jetzt ein bisschen spielen da
sind die nächsten gegner
baumann ich brauchen wir nicht brauchen
wir nicht brauchen nicht sagt zack zack
wieder komplett aussortieren damit wir
eine gut aufgehoben das inventar haben
nein nein warum auch nicht warum haben
wir rock shop in der leiste es
vollkommen sinnlos ok passt aber soweit
man mal kurz zu kaputt ich verband gerne
tiefe sowas dann ist der nächste
und hier noch mal eins hin das sollte
reichen
mein lieber was hast du in essen die
haste nicht oder doch hast du hast du
hast natürlich an den ns aber ich habe
auch ein schwert und da frisst der
momentan ganz gut der kollege hier noch
mal ein artikel scheiße der acht teams
im moment den bogen da ich mit dem
schwert deutlich besser beraten gewesen
und jetzt
was man mit ihr kommt nein ich treffe
ihn einfach nicht wie kann ich ihnen da
nicht hinten können junge tut weh man
warum wird teilweise so ein erbärmliches
range hier jetzt nein es reicht einfach
nicht okay dann als einfach nur mal gar
keinen fall getroffen aber ich hab genug
weil es kein ding passt natürlich kommt
jetzt nicht von hinten ist natürlich
klar
und er hat spielt er jetzt hier nähe
dann hole ich mir jetzt halb den golf24
dafür jetzt läuft nicht weg nicht wirkt
mein spaß ist kämpfen hieß es dann okay
den hammer geholt gut da richtig richtig
stressige runde
wir haben drei diamanten mittlerweile wo
ist der kräftigen crafting table
irgendwo ist das bonn
da hinten vielleicht ich könnte jetzt
ränder mit irgend richtung laufen
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau
wurde spawn ist er hier keinen plan wie
gesagt ich spiele vorne york so selten
dass es einfach eine schande wie wenig
map kenntnis ich hab wird euch das zu
entschuldigen ich habe einfach recht
wenig ahnung wo setze der der crafting
table irgendeinen crafting brauchen wir
nicht mehr den 1
irgendeiner würde mir reichen ist hier
was spawn sieht nichts panik aus herr 10
19 sekunden müssen uns jetzt quasi ins
gesicht blasen des containers wortlosen
sicher oder steht im duden
und jetzt geht's los ok kurz kommt rein
ich habe mit aufgabe habe ich immer so
ein problem leute weil die deathmatch
arenen hier so hart legen
das ist richtig übel die legen so
richtig richtig hart ob er kommt zu mir
erstmal zwei pfeile gegeben tritt der
fall nicht das ist ein super anfang
jetzt wieder auf einer hat sie hat auf
mich durch den in den in den medien in
den medien ihn nennen
jetzt bist du dich in der mittelalter
jetzt gibst du der mittel kommt ibm die
kids gibt es dann ernst
es ist einfach ernst so leute das war's
für heute ich bin gerade eben nicht
gerade das war meine meine mitbewohner
der sich gerade eben entschieden hat ihr
ein bisschen rum zu schreiben ich muss
in der bremer zur rede stellen was soll
man hat ihm jetzt sage mir aus hätte man
munter synchron dazu bewegt ich nicht
der fall
das passiert mal ist die optische
täuschung leute wie gesagt dann nach
oben da lassen wir sehen uns bald wieder
frei und macht's gut und job